[Music]
Luciana dressed me all night tonight
oh really yeah well you look beautiful
whatever whatever was happening it's
working yeah and you've got a whole team
behind you with my daughters are my date
so I was 16 year old Savannah and my
three year old river so they want the
carpet with me I think it was funny
because my daughter the whole time just
kept looking at me going I'm hungry I
was like we all are look around it's
amazing as a dad to like they sort of
like Missa you know the Graduate yeah
yeah she's like what's with all these
people yeah I mean it's afraid that
she'd just be like like to the camera
but it's cuz she does bad by the way we
kind of love that happen you gotta tell
me book the the post with River rose
sleeping and eating and come on she's
hilarious SoCo waste time for a snack
she literally has the quirkiest
personality she's funny kids are funny
they're awesome we're gonna be here
they're gonna be watching your
performance with pink opening the show
tonight things gonna be flying for me
too so Kelly's got rid of the harnesses
I've been joking about it she's gonna be
coming down hashtag hell no mission
impossible stuff what can you teach us
about this performance
you know it's intimate but it's powerful
yeah cuz I don't give it away but it's
an intimate performance it's powerful
not my favorite part of it actually is
that I feel like females always get
pitted against each other and we're too
powerful singers and we're doing our
thing and we respect each other's talent
and it's okay everyone there's room for
everyone you know so yeah that's a great
attitude especially these days I love it
have you and think I got the kids
together at all did you know I think
they're sitting right next to us I don't
know if she's sitting with willow or
my two girls are sitting with me so let
me ask you this what performances are
you looking forward to soon man I mean
I'm looking forward to dying abroad come
on I'm honestly looking forward to me in
pink I'm very excited you're looking
forward to watching pink while you play
like I have a whole performance that I'm
excited about but I'm more excited about
hamdeen we got your whole team with you
tonight you're getting ready for the
review the red carpet for the premiere
what like how do you juggle it all how
do you juggle the kids and get ready and
that people like you know with a lot of
Pinot Noir I'm just kidding I'm just
kidding
it's like every working parent right
we're all working our asses off to be a
good pairing sometimes it works and
sometimes it can mental note that wasn't
you fail it and sometimes you Peppa Clee
fail
[Music]